how's it going guys welcome to code tech
and tutorials my name is matt and we're
going to be talking about design
patterns i'm going to do a whole series
on these cover as many as i can and if i
miss some you guys can always yell at me
in the comments or if i miss something
about the pattern please leave a comment
there's always going to be someone that
knows more than me about these but i'm
going to give you my general
understanding of them and i'm going to
do them in c plus plus because that is
my language of choice you can use your
language of choice if you're using
something with garbage collection these
are going to be made a little bit more
simple but you know every language has
its advantage and disadvantages so you
make your choice there but c plus plus
is my way to go also if you want books
on these there is the gang of four
design patterns these are kind of the
some of the og design patterns and i'll
leave a link to this book down below if
you want to purchase it and have it
available it's super nice to just be
able to chill on a loft and read books
so there's this one and there's a few
other books i want to talk about too
that i've looked at a lot
there's also this game programming
patterns by robert nystrom this one's
really good too so highly recommend it
there's also a free online version but
i'll leave a link to these down below
and purchasing them does help support
the channel by purchasing them through
the links so uh if you want them i would
appreciate if you did it through by the
way so i want to point out one other one
because i know there's a lot of people
interested in making games that is this
game engine black book for doom this one
it's not necessarily about design
patterns but it has a lot of critical
game design stuff so also another one
that's just highly recommended that i'll
leave a link to down below inevitably
you'll see a lot of the design patterns
throughout this book so if you want to
support me further there's a patreon
i'll say that once i'm probably not
going to do it in any of these other
series other than at the very end but
the reason i started finally making this
talk was basically because it was
suggested by someone on my patreon i
have a link up there that allows you to
vote on topics that i cover so any tier
will get you that and of course i
appreciate any extra support
the factory pattern
if you've watched my demo rpg series
you've kind of seen it already with the
way we do items and create monsters and
stuff like that so let's open up an
editor and get going all right i think
i'm just going to go ahead and do a new
project or solution here
just using visual studio 2022 you can
use whatever you build system and
editor you're comfortable with doesn't
really matter a whole lot
but we're also going to use cmake just
to kind of keep it cross-platform
because this is going to be up on github
and i'm going to just call this uh
design patterns
all right looking good so it's going to
give us kind of a blank solution and
we're just going to make some folders
and uh here we go we got design patterns
with the cmake here and well the way it
creates this uh starting folder is it
has a top level cmake that adds a
subdirectory for the design patterns so
you can kind of do this at will now
we're going to have some additional sub
directories and we're just going to
structure this so i'm going to make a
new folder and i'm just going to call it
factory so in this little cmake here i'm
going to just delete these design
patterns here and the cmake um we're
also going to yeah we're just gonna take
the cmake and put it in factory and
we're just gonna once again make yet
another layer there we go and all this
is gonna have is add subdirectory once
again or factory and this will expand as
we go i will keep the top level one nice
and clean and we'll just keep adding to
this design pattern once as we go
for example we'll make new folders later
but this first episode we're just going
to focus on the factory pattern and
we're just going to make a little
example of it so you can see what it
does but first i want to talk about a
little the theory behind it before we
dive in too much because of course with
any of these design patterns you need to
know their use cases or at least have an
understanding of their use cases because
some of them are useful at certain times
basically and other times they're
redundant and kind of pointless so
let me pull a few threads and we'll talk
about it all right so here's a thread on
stack overflow that i thought was pretty
helpful someone just asked when you use
it instead of just a constructor because
basically all the factory is is a bit of
a glorified constructor now the main
point of it is you want to use this
factory when the constructor is not
enough or when you want to do some
additional things and the constructor
doesn't quite handle it because to be
quite frank the constructor is a factory
if you have a class and has a
constructor you just you know you make a
new object in your sensory essentially
factoring them out but sometimes you
actually want a front end to your class
that
basically handles producing stuff and
there can be many reasons why really
depending on your program if you're
doing something with connections maybe
you want to manage those connections if
you're producing some sort of objects
that render in your game maybe you want
to carefully manage some of the the
stuff that it's creating there because
it you know talks to the resources so
the big point of it is the factory kind
of is the middle man between strip
construction your class in
uh also it's sometimes quite a bit
redundant it's one of actually the least
used patterns after a while from what i
understand because it often
just isn't necessary anymore but
nonetheless it is still a pattern and we
are going to cover it
so there's all kinds of things in this
thread i'll leave a link to it also down
below but you can uh you can see that a
lot of people have a lot of different
opinions on it
some people say things like one
situation where i find factory makes
sense is when your object creates on or
relies on creating several other objects
as well because you know you can have
you know you have your constructor but
sometimes you want a factory to produce
multiple things and kind of put them
together and produce them and put them
together so that's that's one case but
uh there are others all right so let's
finally get into the code all right back
to visual studio here in our factory
folder we're just gonna make a
let's make a main.cpp we
just need something to create so i like
doing things game related just because i
think they're easy to understand
you know we could do places we could do
creatures we could do items for now
we're just going to do preachers so i'm
going to make a a creature and i'm just
making a dot h here and we're just going
to work up a class real quick a little
creature class i'll make this bigger
so
in this file this creature.h we're going
to have class
creature
and
publicly
we're going to have a constructor of
course
we'll have a creature and we're just
going to go ahead and define that and
right
here in the header for the moment just
to save space and
we'll we're going to need a destructor
as well now there's a lot of different
ways of doing this
people often like to make these virtual
because just a base creature doesn't
tell you much so we're going to have
different types of creatures and we're
going to factory them out and i'm going
to show you a few tricks along the way
and of course once again i'll say this
there are many different ways to do this
this is not the only way this is just
how i like to do it uh at times you know
we uh
need some fields here to fill out and
work with so it's pretty safe to assume
that every creature has uh let's just
let's just pick a few things a few stats
let's have let's have an integer for
hit points
and we'll default it to one you know
we're going to do away with this
constructor we're going to let it be
implied that'll be fine because with all
these equals here it basically implies a
default constructor and you don't
necessarily need to type it out sql plus
the back end will handle that for you
but your language may vary so do what
you got to do
so we'll have another one we'll just
have speed and we'll make the default
speed one and we'll also have just a
attack and we'll start that at one as
well actually we'll start that one at
zero because some things are just
totally harmless but uh you know maybe
think some things don't really move
either like an amoeba doesn't move too
much probably has a speed of zero that's
a weird example but you probably get the
point but everything's got to have at
least one hit point because we're going
to consider zero eight points not um
conscious or something like that well
there that would bring up another debate
because a lot of things aren't conscious
but are still alive
lasai okay fine we'll start the hit
points at zero i'm defeating myself with
my own logic so anyways the whole point
here is we have a creature um that is
that is something and this is what we're
going to factory out now we want some
other virtual
methods here this virtual thing is
optional let's just get rid of virtual
let's not make it too confusing here
those will be handy a little later with
some tricks
but here we just have a base creature
and now what we want to do let's we
could do it in the same file down below
but instead let's make a new file and
let's just call this you know we'll make
our first creature let's just call it a
dog so just make a dog.h we gotta
include our creature
and we're gonna make a class
dog and it's gonna publicly inherit from
creature that way it gets all those
stats
this one's going to be a little
different
now we're going to private here and this
one we're just going to make the the
stuff different
so let's have a default constructor for
the dog here almost doge
um and the doge is going to take hp
speed and
attack all right we could have other
stuff you know anything your creature
might want to do we could have it uh
we're gonna have a dude or we can have
like hunger levels whatever you want to
do it's totally up to you and what
you're designing but we already got all
the fields in here because
it's a dog but another thing we might
want is just like a whole set of getters
and stuff so i'm going to slap those in
the creature real quick that way we have
them available for all the subclasses
and they'll have to type them a bunch of
times so we're just going to have ant
i don't think it's lowercase or camel
case uh get hp
and that's just going to
return the hit points and we'll have
that down the line for all this stuff
i'm just gonna do some copy paste action
there we go that makes it easy enough
that we have access to those private
variables but we can only
set them the normal way actually you
know a point of making something in here
virtual is uh we don't want to be able
to instantiate just a plain old creature
so that that's a thing you can do so
maybe we want uh something to do that um
so we'll just make a spawn function
that's easy enough now this is kind of
putting the factory inside the creature
itself which might be a little a little
weird but it's not that big of a deal so
we got a spawn here and we got a dog
over here so this might actually be
better as like a dog factory or
something like that because then we
would just uh you know we'd have the
same constructor stuff but then we'd
have now we want to override the void
the spawn function and have it do
something so what would it do
all right so let's uh let's maybe back
up a little bit and just think of this
slightly different way all right so we
have this creature it's a very base type
let's let's just get rid of the spawn
and let's just say we're going to put
all our main supported ones in here so
maybe we're doing a game with uh you
know very specific stuff so we'll just
actually take this uh dog here and just
put it down below and we don't even need
to like put anything super
fancy here so our game has dogs right
maybe you want to do this for everything
i'm just going to keep it real simple so
uh we'll have a cat as well
and then we'll have uh we'll have a
mouse sure that's fine maybe have
fantasy creatures like dragons and
goblins and elves and stuff that's
that's fine i'm just just keeping it
super simple here so all of these have
uh they have these stats
uh have all this stuff ready to go now
if we want to make a factory of them
we're going to need to do it a little
differently so uh so example we have a
dog factory and a uh well let's start
with the factory so let's actually name
this like uh creature
factory or it's just spawner we'll just
call this spawner now of course you
could separate all these classes into
separate files some people might like
that better but let's uh let's go ahead
and get rid of this we'll call this uh
spot spawner and we just need a base
spawner here so it's going to have a uh
destructive of course
spawner like so uh and we probably want
to make this virtual yeah let's make a
virtual virtual spawner
instructor
we'll need to do anything uh right now
and i guess we don't need the semicolons
at the end of
the definitions here okay yeah we're
good there all right
but we also want for the spawner it
doesn't we don't want it to do anything
on its own which is something we want to
inherit from so we're going to have
another virtual function
called
just spawn but uh we got to decide what
we're spawning spawn creature
sure that could be fine gotcha okay so
we'll have the spawn creature having
equal zero just like that we don't
really need any private functions this
basically means we can't instantiate
creature on its own or the spawner on
its own and uh well we kind of want to
do the same thing with this uh creature
so let's just make this virtual as well
we'll come back to this creature one and
i want to show you another little trick
but
essentially we'll just leave it like
that all right let's go back to the
spawner
so now we want to have like a class for
each one of these so we'll have a dog
spawner
this is going to be essentially our
factory but we need to inherit from the
spawner and of course we're going to
need to implement this spawn creature so
let me see if we have the helper yeah
implement pure virtuals see no it's uh
not quite enough smart enough to do it
but uh we can just uh copy this and
clean it up a little bit oh we need a
void or something here or we need it to
return something that actually spawn and
of course it's always going to return a
creature of some sort and since these
are virtual we can use the power of
polymorphism to always just return a
creature but it can be the correct
creature as we go and uh these have
different you know these don't have any
different things they have different
names but we haven't like given them any
special stuff so we should probably do
that at some point here like the main
way we're going to do that is we do it
with like the default constructor and we
would give it hit points
something else now it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense since well
yeah let's say a dog always have at
least one hit points and it always has a
speed of at least one cell and it always
has the attack of at least one and that
would be fine maybe we'll you know we'll
adjust a little bit maybe doug's got uh
three hit points uh speed of three and
an attack of three and we'll just kind
of go down the line of power in general
you know this is not gonna be a perfect
thing but let's let's just get these set
up because i'm going to assume here that
dogs are a little bit stronger than cats
cats are a little bit stronger than mice
so we can just do a nice scaling one two
three is all i'm going to do here so we
can essentially just uh copy this down
like so change these to twos and this
will just give us a nice semblance of a
hierarchy of the power of creatures now
obviously they'll have their own little
special abilities which would make a
whole lot of sense too but we're not
going to worry about that too much right
now mouse cat what's a mouse cat you
guys ever seen that cartoon cat dog what
about mouse cat you've seen miles all
right well you get the point here so now
they have slightly different stats from
their default constructors which is uh
totally fine
and that needs expanded a little bit
naturally if we want to actually make it
a little more useful but it depends on
your game but okay so let's take this
dog spawner let's override the spawn
creature let's see if it lets us do it
properly now we've no
could not be implemented blah blah
something anyway we need to take this
and basically we're going to return a
new dog and that's that's it that'll
spawn him so you can make a dog spawner
and you can call a spawn creature yeah
or or just spawn i like i like this just
being named spawn it's uh
enough and it'll return you a new dog
now it's really important to realize at
least the language without garbage
collection like c plus plus this is
returning a pointer to the dog and it's
doing it as a creature so when you use
it as a dog you're going to have to cast
it to a dog
well specifically if it has its own
stuff now this is getting into
polymorphism logic so i don't want to
get too deep into it but right now the
dog only has this base stuff so you
don't even really need to cast it it's
when the dog has like well maybe it has
a uh just another field of its own
that's when you need to
cast it to a dog to use its own special
dog fields so hope that makes sense so i
guess in this case a dog would have
something like bark
well we'll just make a function called
bark we probably want to do this
publicly for the dog we should we gotta
put public gear it's gonna assume
everything private we don't want that so
yeah we'll get we'll get a little bark
function here uh yeah i guess it makes
sense to go down the line let's uh of
course make these public or else it's
not going to work uh
void meow
and
a squeak with a mouse that's pretty cool
that differentiates them a little bit
and that way we can uh mess with the
casting if we need to
void mouse i mean void squeak what do
you suppose
my brain's not functioning there we go
is that right no it has a u in there
somewhere oh my gosh how do i not know
how to spell squeak oh it's the the use
right here okay some of these english
words trip me up so don't feel bad a lot
of people always say they did they're
bad in english or whatever i'm i'm worse
it's my native language don't feel too
bad all right so let's make some quick
functions here they don't need to
actually do anything we could have a c
out that just says whatever real quick
if we wanted to but we really just want
to get it in there just to make sure we
can actually call the function all right
so there we go we got a nice little
dog cat mouth system they're all
creatures and we can spawn them by
making spawners uh just like so we can
do the same for
the others so i'm just going to copy
these down real quick make a cat spawner
that returns new
cat
a
mouse spawner
returns a new mouse and here we
basically have a factory system
uh started out so now let's give this a
quick test
and then i'll show you one other trick
and we can go from there all right so in
our main here let's just have it main
and we'll just go ahead and create a
spawner so we'll just include the
spawner now the spawner includes
creature first thing so just by
including the spawner we are getting all
the definitions for the creature and
then all the spawn stuff so it should be
ready to go so let's just instantiate
one let's say all right well obviously
your gamer program or whatever is going
to be a lot more complicated whenever
you instantiate your objects it's going
to make sense for what you're doing but
we're just basically running a test here
so we're just going to start out well
let's start with a dog actually yeah
dog's fine and we're going to have this
uh be dog one like shiloh we're just
going to name him dog one and
we're going to call this spawner
well the spawner is an object so if we
want the dog spawner to work like that
we're going to have to go we're going to
need a spawner so we're going to need a
dog spawner
we'll just call it ds so ds
and then we're going to call the
function spawn and that is going to
return a pointer to a new creature that
is a dog and we should be able to
show its stats so i'm going to go ahead
and include
uh iostream real quick here just so we
can confirm that it's a dog
and
i'm going to do one other thing real
quick i'm going to go back to creature
let's make these return
well just trying to think how to
properly call spark mail squeak i guess
you know it's just going to make a
compiler error if it fails so we don't
necessarily need to see out stuff
because if we try to call for example
dog one
we get all these public functions and
you can see there's bark because it's a
dog but what we could do is if we have a
big array of these and we're creating a
bunch maybe you don't necessarily know
what it is yet you could just do
creature and that way
um it only has the ones from creature it
doesn't have bark yet so you would have
to cast it first you would have to go
all right um a dog each equals
dog one except you need to to cast it
and make sure the cast is successful so
we could do dynamic cast
to a dog the dog won and if this
succeeds a dog will not be null and then
we should be able to call it okay in
this way we should be able to uh make
this dog one which is just a creature uh
actually bark however you've got to
watch out for null because if this fails
it's null so if you have a big array of
a bunch of creatures and you want to see
if it's a dog you try to cast it to a
dog if it succeeds it is if it fails
it's null so you got to be careful
though because if it's no you don't try
to call something in it otherwise you're
going to get a uh your program is going
to crash so you need to be careful about
that kind of stuff in c plus plus let's
just work some some cool features with
this dynamic casting
how far do we want to go with this i
don't know as far as we want to guess
because we could go for example
i'm just going to call these c1
c2 and c3
so maybe you have some sort of
randomizer that might spawn different
things
uh because you know there's a dog
spawner let's also make a cat spawner
we'll call this one cs for cat spawner
and let's say we have our now spawner
just a quick example here of putting
them in a array no maybe have something
yeah randomize is creating them but
so here let's make a a cat
and a mouse
and let's just spawn each but they're
all just there's creatures so instead of
having a c1 cc two c3 we could instead
have a creature array
uh and we'll just call this creatures
let's have a pointer here actually
yeah let's have a creature here and
let's say there are just three for now
so that's the size of the array now this
might be better as a vector or something
but of course we should initialize all
these to the null
null pointer null pointer null pointer
there we go that should do for now just
a quick initializer list and then we
want to go through and create all these
now you'd probably want to do these on a
loop obviously but uh you know for sake
of example we're going to just make a
quick row like this and that way we can
uh just go down the line there we go so
there's three different types of
creatures in here but they're all just
creatures so now when we go to to do
stuff we want a little uh unpacking
array so
we'll just start it at zero we'll just
do a quick quick hack here now there's
ways to do this better dynamically
obviously and if you want to do that and
change it on github and and make pull
requests you can that'd be cool but
that's uh up to you so y i is less than
three i plus plus
and let's just do the thing so now uh
let's do a switch statement here so we
want to check if it is
uh what kind of creature it is basically
uh so we want to switch on the creature
type now this gets a little tricky here
because we need to
do something to see what it is
or you know we'll just do you know
switch statement would be better in the
long run but we'll just do a quick if
right here so we can say uh we can just
check
castings here i guess would be the case
yeah so let's try the first casting uh
we'll say
uh let's make a dog
and cast the first one
dynamic cast
to a dog pointer
and it's a creature
i could spell correctly that'd be great
oh there's gotta be parentheses like
that let's do the dynamic cast syntax
correctly so let's try to cast the first
creature to the dog so if dog so
basically if it's not null since this is
the pointer then we could go uh
dog bark
however if it is null then it's not a
dog it's something else now we know this
one is a dog because we see it right
here but if you have a big complicated
program with it being randomly allocated
and whatnot you're not necessarily going
to know so these dynamic casts you can
do a run time and see what it actually
is now of course yeah demo rpg we did a
bunch of this kind of stuff so it
happened a lot in there but you want to
do the same thing for other stuff so if
it is a dog and you want to return
basically because you don't want to do
any further checks necessarily but i
guess you could it's not going to it's
not going to necessarily fail
but we're probably done if you're done
you can return not return continue which
will basically start the next loop
continue that'll just start the next
loop with continue there but uh
you know we could we could keep going so
let's just copy all this let's say what
if it's a cat you know
uh we don't want this to be zero we want
this to be i because we're going through
a loop cat cat dot yeah that way we
don't call these if it's null so
only if it actually is casted correctly
that's when we call these and you can
see that uh even the auto syntax is kind
of assuming
that it casts correctly but it's not
necessarily going to it could be null so
that's why you got you got to do this if
and check if it's null or not
and we'll do one real quick for mouse
and then we'll give this a quick run
and you know real quick i'm just going
to go in here and i'm going to go over
to creature i just want these uh bark
now squeak to actually do something
because it'll just make it a lot more
clear so let's just make a quick
standard see how all right arf on that
one and uh we'll do it on these other
ones too now
i don't know whatever a squeak sounds
like close enough okay but you get the
point here so now we should see those
different terminologies they'll come up
when we call those functions there
so we have our main here now we actually
haven't made our cmake let's fix this
cmake
so we're going to have this one's called
factory
old factory and it relies on main.cpp
let's put the headers in here too
creature.h
spawner
dot h
and there we go give that a save and see
if it files correctly oh we have this
target thing going on i don't i don't
normally use this target thing but
whatever we'll uh we'll fill it out it
just came with the default thing cmake
generation finished uh so now we can
bring up our renault with control tilde
here or you can open up your own
terminal now let's put it down here
and uh you can see we have a terminal so
we can see what we're looking at we can
go to the out
we can go to the build
this might be really tiny so i apologize
i don't know if i can make this one
bigger no i can't it just beeps at me
very loudly when i try to okay but here
we can see we got the x64 debug x64
debug and in here we have a
uh design patterns and then we have
factory
deep in there and you can see no we
haven't we haven't built anything we got
build.ninja um we basically need to run
our cmake on this whole thing
so let's back up a bunch i thought it
was going to auto run it but whatever
let's run a manually cmake
uh build into oh well let me check
something all right so i'm going to just
go to this top level right click it and
go to open explorer and we'll just going
to have a peek around and see what it's
generated here
um
so yeah al build debug uh design
patterns factory you know c make files
not okay so nothing here we should see
like a solution or something but it
doesn't seem to have done that so maybe
we got a bit of an error i don't see an
error though let's just uh let's just
check this out let's configure it to x64
release and see what it does
oh we got a bit of an error here in our
code oh we're trying to set private
variables uh so
for inheritance we're going to do these
as protected that way whatever is
inheriting from them has access to them
they're they're semi-private but uh we
can still set them in the subclasses now
so
we'll just do that real quick all right
and now let's see if we can get this
going
let's look at the debug one yeah we're
not we're not seeing it yet we should
see a solution we got cmake install i
don't know what's going on here i think
i maybe need to set something about this
build system that i haven't yet so uh oh
here we go so we want to we want to
click this up here and set it to the
factory.exe then we should be able to
actually use our play button here we go
we'll hit up our play button and it's
going to build do the whole thing all
right and looks like we have
successfully done it we went through all
three we got an arf but al meow and anik
so it did detect all three but if
they're randomly different it would just
work and uh there you go so that's
that's a very quick example of a factory
now someone mentioned and so we'll
expand this a little a little further
because as you can see someone mentioned
uh if you have multiple things being
tied together that's better for a
factory because we don't really need the
factory here i mean if we're just
looking at this it's it's really
redundant we don't even we don't need
these spawners we could literally just
go uh
creature equals you know we could just
set one of them to to new dog for
example and that would work pretty much
the same as the spawner because the
spawner is essentially just constructing
one and returning the memory so it makes
the whole spawner kind of pointless in a
way
um and and that's and that's why this
pattern sometimes isn't used and that's
where it's like
you know it's not that useful if this is
all you're doing so
let's make it a little more fancy so we
have these spawners there whatever
actually uh we'll leave them but what if
for example we want to spawn a pack of
dogs so let's go
class uh pack pack of dogs all right
so this is where it's going to get a
little more interesting oops make this
correct
public spawner so for example this could
return
just a whole bunch so public uh let's
have it return a creature
spawn
so now do we want to return one or do we
want to return a bunch probably a bunch
well let's think about this a little bit
here
if it's going to be an array well we can
work with that from a pointer but it's
going to get a little messy and maybe
you know some of the dogs have different
stats maybe you want a alpha dog that
has bigger stats so the point would be
that you can create a spawner that that
spawns it does a bunch of things and
returns the whole thing so
you might want something to signify that
and uh i don't know if i'm going to get
into that too much here you can be
creative and come up with this if you
want but uh that would be like a better
spawner because rather than just
creating one dog we could actually make
you know we could basically generate
encounters this way and and stuff like
that but the whole thing would just
start becoming a bit different so uh it
would be something like
uh you know it'd still be a return new
dog but
then we probably want to do some some
more randomization or add some
parameters
like
right now the way that these are
this constructor doesn't take any
parameters
all of these are hidden behind protected
so we don't have access to them so we
could change these or we could put like
we could have it actually take variables
in the constructor and then we could
construct different ones in our spawners
and you know that would be a little
better
for something that way we could have an
alpha dog and make it bigger and stuff
like that now it's it's probably getting
a little confusing at this point but uh
just keep that in mind and if you want
to view an implementation of a
multi-spawner you could do that like we
could add to this uh let me think about
this actually let's let's get rid of
this function so let's go back to this
dog spawner and let's go
uh creature star spawn spawn pack in
this
we could you know we just basically have
to add to an array and return that whole
thing but also you need to know how many
are in the array otherwise you're gonna
get hit with some trouble going through
the array well when you could do some
tricks like you could
you know you could check the memory
sizes and all that and figure it out but
at this point it would honestly make a
little bit more sense to just do like a
vector or something so let's uh let's
just do that real quick as an example
we'll knock that out
so go standard vector
creature star
so we're going to return a vector of
creature stars and it's it's a pack of
dogs that says so
maybe we'll do a random amount so we
need some sort of randomizer i'm gonna
i'm gonna not do the randomizing right
now just because you know we'd have to
bring in the whole random library and
start going through all that but uh
that's and that's not necessarily what
this is about but now you know you
probably want some random stuff so we'll
just make like
uh
let's just do a for loop let's say a
pack of dogs and you probably want a
random size and you know random the
alpha's power and all all that we're not
going to do that it's just it's just too
much trouble uh for this particular
tutorial we'll start i zero i is less
than i don't know we'll say five it's
gonna be packed five dogs uh that'll
that'll be fine for now and uh oh we
need a return vector here so let's just
take this type
and we'll call we'll just call this
variable the return pack so we'll just
go return
pack dot push back
and it'll just be new dog over and over
it'd be better with random stats i'll
say that again because right now they're
just going to be all the same type but
at the end after we go through this loop
and fill out the whole thing we can just
re-return our return pack
there are other fancier ways you could
do this like you could have this
just for example you could
have this void and you could have this
be right here and do it this way so if
you're returning multiple things
you could pass them in
by reference and we'll just call this
the alpac and then you could do it this
way so there's some varying different
ways this is kind of better if you're
returning multiple things pass in by
reference so it's something you actually
have access to and you don't want to
return you just have to fill it out and
it's done so boom fill out your memory
with spawn pack and uh there we go
that'd be that'd be five dogs basically
and this way let's go ahead and just do
that let's do a pack um
spawn
a pack of dogs test so here we go uh
basic creature
oh yeah we'll do some comments
test uh casting creatures to proper type
okay so spawn a pack of dogs test how
we're going to do this well we need our
vector
of uh
creatures
let's call this one dog pack and now we
want to take the same dog spawner
because we just added the functionality
to it and now we have spawn pack and
need something to fill out which is
going to be this dog pack
and there we go that should be it and
now we should essentially be able to go
through this same loop
um well we already know they're all dogs
but we'd probably have this enough in a
function you know you want to probably
separate your for loop or your whole
casting thing rather than copy paste
but uh yeah maybe i'll just do that okay
we'll just i'll set real quick uh
test casting types okay i don't know
we'll just do that that works for now
well now forget it i'll just we'll keep
going through the loop see the problem
with that is that well this one's a
vector so actually we can just use some
c plus plus functions we already know we
got the dog pack so we can just do like
const auto
by reference
and we'll just say thing and in the dog
pack so there we go we can get every
element in the dog pack here and uh it's
just gonna be i think no longer need the
eye
i don't know this might well we'll have
a compiler error if it doesn't like that
this is const auto i think maybe we
actually want a pointer here i don't
know i'll try it like this let's see
what it does let's see if it fails or
not let's go back to here let's hit hit
our little run button so let's see what
happens there we go okay we got our
first three that's the same as before
that was uh this code from there uh and
then we got our whole dog pack
and it's just five dogs all going harf
so we know that that spawning a whole
pack works too and if there happened to
be some cats and mice in this spawn so
maybe we have even a more advanced
spawner that spawns random ones it would
still properly do this casting because
or it would still properly do the right
thing because we got this casting
so it doesn't hurt to have it i guess is
the point and i guess the thing we want
to break down into a function would be
all these right here because you would
just pass it this try all the casting
and see what happens
um but that's that's pretty much it all
right this is getting a little long you
probably see the point of these of this
factory pattern hopefully you've had
some fun i'm just going to show you one
last little cool trick and then we'll
end this episode
now this last little trick actually
comes from the game programming patterns
book and that's where i learned in the
least and it's basically the whole
prototype method so if you have a
creature let's see we got we got these
creatures here now obviously they're all
the same they all have three hit points
three speed three attack whatever uh
let's just make a fifth one and we're
gonna we're gonna have this one be a
prototype uh creature so we'll call this
we'll do something a little different
with this one we'll have a class called
a uh
i don't know let's do a dragon dragon
this time no we'll just do blizzard
closer is fine it's a public creature
and we're just going to make this one a
little different this one's going to be
this one won't need a spawner and you'll
see why here shortly
because we're going to do some stuff
differently with it so let's take this
lizard
and let's go
uh let's actually take variables in this
time and hp and
speed and attack and i don't know what
else might a lizard have oh it'll make a
hiss sound we'll just go void
yes sure why not and uh we'll just do
this i guess a lizard hisses
there we go all right but anyway we want
rather than just setting them directly
they're actually going to be set to uh
whatever we pass in so we've got all
types of lizards and don't worry i'm
getting to the actual point a second i
just got to do this little setup so now
we want another method in here all right
and this method would be
virtual
blown all right so
we're going to have it do
we're going to have it return a creature
and you probably want this pure virtual
i'm not making it pure virtual
specifically because i haven't
implemented it in this dog cat mouse
setup so it's going to complain if i
don't but normally rather than return no
pointer you would have this equal to
zero but i'm just returning their
pointer in case it's a dog cat or else
because clone's not going to work on
them basically
it's just going to return null but we're
going to make clone work for this lizard
and the way we do that is we just we
just implement it we go
future star
clone return
new lizard and it's going to have its
current hit points
speed
and attack
so essentially what this will do is it
will create a whole new lizard but it's
going to have the exact same stats as
this current lizard so with this sort of
setup you can you can clone your
creature and you don't even really need
a spawner anymore you just make an
initial prototype lizard then you just
call clone whenever you need new ones so
it's sort of a variant on the factory
design pattern is to do this clone sort
of thing and it's super cool too really
so uh i'm just going to put it down here
clone test so we're going to take that
lizard
we're going to go
creature star
lizard equals new
lizard we we didn't make a factory for
this oh it needs some stats i don't know
we'll just type in some random things
uh there we go it's a really beefy
lizard uh what are we missing here see
we don't we didn't make a spawner for it
whatever it doesn't matter if it's fine
uh we're skipping it but essentially
pretend we did the same thing here
actually whatever let's do it let's do
it let's go lizard spawner public
spawner
gotta fill out this pure virtual
return new lizard now the lizard is
different um because
uh we we don't have a constructor that
takes nothing the constructor needs
something which is essentially how we
should do the others but uh whatever so
maybe want some random but we just we're
gonna put something in there for now
just so we can test it
so we probably want a lizard spawner
uh what if i call that let's respond
yeah i just i literally just said the
word call ls ls dot spawn there we go
and that's going to give us that lizard
i'm short cutting a little bit to make
this easier but now the point here is
yeah sure we got our lizard but and it's
going to make its hiss sound so if we do
this cast thing except to lizard should
be able to get that going i'm just going
to call it liz liz the lizard
and we now need our lizard here oh it
doesn't like this key word uh i'll just
call it liz c for this creature there's
a creature i don't know and then we're
gonna cast it here and we gotta make
sure the cast is successful so
we gotta see if it's not null so if it's
not null then we'll call its function of
this
also now we can clone it hope we're
casting
here all right that's fine but now we
also have the clone function test uh
cast test clone now let's see let's test
cloning that's cloning
all right
so we obviously want to know uh that it
uh we want to make sure it actually
casts correctly first because well let's
see i guess we're just going to get null
pointer if it's not cast
correctly so actually it's fine we don't
even need to do
this casting test because the way we
have designed it was pure virtual we
would absolutely have to but otherwise
we can just go uh let's make another
lizard here clone lizard equals and we
can just take this original creature one
liz c
dot clone and there we go we should be
able to get the clone blizzard okay this
needs to be creature too
because uh the clone returns creature so
we can once again test cast of the clone
even though we're cloning it while it is
still just a creature uh deep down
inside is actually a lizard so this
clone is not going to return the
creature clone but the one that it's
actually is so it should return this one
here or use this function and that's
just the way that c plus plus is
designed
so once again we will dynamic cast this
cloned lizard
uh lizard lone clone lizard lizard clone
i don't know i have to name these
variables something so let's just make
sure that it's not null make sure it's
actually a lizard and we'll call the
hiss so we should see two hisses here we
should see uh you know after all the
five barks in a row we should see one
hiss and then a two hits and the very
last hits will be uh the successful
things return
exit success at the end of this
program
sure then that wait sooner but it
doesn't matter all right so if we get
two hisses at the end we know that
that's all successful and there we go
so very good there's the there's a
little bit about the clone method all
right there's some some factory testing
and playing around with factories this
is this was a very this episode went a
lot longer than i expected i was hoping
to do it i kid you not i was hoping to
do this in 10 minutes but
you know i keep looking up here my
camera's not there anymore it's down
here so thanks guys greatly appreciate
all of you who support hope you learned
something if you did consider hitting
the like button if you want to see more
code stuff consider subscribing my name
is matt you'll see me around and uh if
you want to support further links down
below patreon all that stuff uh love you
guys peace out